PRIYANKA VERGADIA: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to all of them.
So if you didn't see APIs,
microservices, and service mesh
talk, then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is the relationship
and interplay
between service
mesh, infrastructure,
and API management?
When to use each?
Let's find out.
Companies are on this journey
of moving from monoliths
to microservices.
In a microservice's
infrastructure,
an application is
really a collection
of loosely coupled services.
And we do this to gain
increased product velocity,
manage complexity of
code, admit heterogeneity,
and empower developers.
An alternative to
decomposing systems
is to wrap them with an API
to make them accessible.
Now, what is an API?
Well APIs are just
communication contracts.
Every system that can
receive requests has an API.
What is a service mesh?
It's a way to build more
intelligence into the network.
Well what does that mean?
In a monolith, integration
between modules
was presumed secure.
In a microservices
architecture, the integration
between services and
request traverse a network.
Therefore, we need mutual
TLS to secure those requests.
But mutual TLS
needs to be managed,
and we need each service
to be able to discover
the other services that
it might be calling.
And we want services
to all [? adhere ?]
to communication policies
related to retries, timeouts,
authentication, and we
want all the telemetry data
from each service.
So we need some sort of
system to support all of that.
Let us delegate all of that
complexity of enforcing
the communication protocols
to a standalone proxy known
as a sidecar proxy,
or the envoy proxy.
This is the model
that Istio uses
Istio still starts with the
envoy proxy as a sidecar,
and adds a set of pieces to
help manage and provision
the distributed set of proxies.
Envoy proxy allows you to
manage the inbound calls
through ingress gateway,
and outbound calls
through egress gateway.
So you can put the checks
and regulations on inbound
and the outbound traffic.
This is what we can call a
managed mesh of services.
Well, why use a service mesh?
It's to connect, secure,
control, and observe
our microservices
infrastructure.
Now let's talk about
the management of APIs.
As we said, APIs represent
the communication contract.
And as we share APIs to
clients outside the network,
we want to manage requests that
conform to those contracts.
You would use API management
to help developers discover
the APIs, to modernize your
old legacy APIs into a more
modern REST-based format, and
to properly report and monitor
the usage of your APIs.
Let's combine the two
concepts together, now.
Managing microservices
and API management.
We've got our systems, a
legacy system and a monolith.
The internal clients
connect directly.
The external clients connect
through the API gateway.
Because we are on the
microservices journey,
we are decomposing
the monolith into
multiple distinct services.
And we update the
internal app to keep pace
with the changing endpoints.
And then, we
introduce new services
to add more capabilities, which
is the onset of complexity.
To simplify this, here's
a clean way of doing it.
We want to use service mesh
infrastructure, like Istio,
to manage the communication
amongst and between services.
And the API management to
manage the communication
from the clients.
To summarize, here's
the mental model.
You select your infrastructure,
your thousands of services
are built on that layer.
Those services
are to be managed.
Some services
expose shared APIs.
You need to manage all of
those shared APIs as well.
And clients delivering
end-user experiences then
use those APIs.
So that's the mental model
that we found to be useful.
If you would like to see
the full talk and the demo,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to Cloud YouTube channel
for more great Next
Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]